The Billion Dollar Speech that Sank a Major
Company
Have you ever said something that you ended
up immediately regretting or wanted to take
back straight away?
Well, unless your words cost someone nearly
a billion dollars, then you haven’t messed
up quite as bad as Gerald Ratner did back
in 1991.
Yet…
Ratner was the CEO of the Ratners Group, jewellers
that shook up the usually stiff and inflexible
jewellery market by aiming some of its products
at the working class through a chain of shops
colloquially known as “Ratners.”
Although the chain was widely ridiculed and
considered “gaudy,” “tacky” and “cheap”
by the press and other jewellers, many wanting
to buy jewellery and not break the bank flocked
to the stores, turning Ratners into a household
name throughout England in the 1980s.
This unprecedented move was primarily spearheaded
by Ratner himself and it turned what was once
a small, family-owned chain into a billion
dollar business, threatening other jewellers
the world over.
You see, if everyone owns and wears jewellery,
and it is sold cheaply, it loses much of its
prestige and perceived value which has long
made certain mostly worthless and common jewellery
items extremely expensive.
Ratner started working for the company in
1965 when he was a fresh-faced teen.
In the 19 years he worked for the company,
it made almost no market headway.
When he inherited the company in 1984, he
expanded it from about 150 shops to over 2,000
in just six years, capturing over 50% of the
UK’s jewellery market.
Ratner appeared to be a business prodigy.
In his autobiography, Gerald Ratner: The Rise
and Fall… and Rise Again, Ratner claimed
that his success in the 1980s was down to
an experience he had when he was younger at
Petticoat Lane Market.
At this market, Ratner noticed that it wasn’t
the vendors selling the best goods that got
the most sales or interest from customers,
it was the vendors who yelled the loudest
and had the most garish, eye-catching displays.
Ratner eagerly applied this concept to his
own business when he took over the Ratner
Group in 1984, and he made sure that all of
the shops in the Ratners chain had bright
orange displays that loudly advertised their
prices and deals.
This, combined with the rock-bottom prices
the chain was offering, saw sales explode.
At the peak of his company’s success, Ratner
was invited to speak to the Institute of Directors,
a group of high-powered businessmen and journalists,
about how he’d made his company so big so
fast.
The speaking engagement, which Ratner himself
now refers to as “the speech,” has since
gone down as one of the biggest blunders in
business history.
Though the speech was going well for a while,
the fateful moment came when a person in attendance
innocently asked Ratner how his company was
able to afford to sell things so cheaply;
his now infamous response was as follows:
“…We also do cut-glass sherry decanters
complete with six glasses on a silver-plated
tray that your butler can serve you drinks
on, all for £4.95.
People say, ‘How can you sell this for such
a low price?’
I say, because it’s total crap.”
He went on to say that some of the earrings
sold by the Ratner Group were
“cheaper than an M&S prawn sandwich but
probably wouldn’t last as long.”
Though Ratner claims he intended the comments
as a joke (though from the sound of it a joke
at the expense of his customers) and thought
because it was a private event that nothing
said would be reported to the public, the
journalists listening didn’t see it that
way on either count, and the very next day
his comments were national news.
The effect on the company’s profits were
practically instantaneous.
Almost overnight shares in the company dropped
by £500 million or around $800 million (about
£936 million / $1.6 billion today) and customers
began avoiding Ratners stores like the plague.
The phrase “doing a Ratner” entered the
English lexicon as a term for really screwing
up.
Just a year after Ratner’s speech, Ratners
stores began closing down by the hundreds,
resulting in thousands of jobs being axed.
The company claimed that the dramatic loss
of profits was due to “a shift in consumer
spending habits,” which is kind of true
in a sense, but it’s pretty obvious from
the five hundred million pound punch to the
gut they received just a year prior, that
it was really due to Ratner’s speech.
Ratner resigned in November of 1992 and the
company, in an effort to distance itself further
from Ratner, unceremoniously re-branded themselves
as the “Signet Group” in 2002.
Though his speech had cost his company hundreds
of millions of dollars, Ratner himself came
out of the scandal relatively unscathed, as
noted in this interview with him, “I sold
my shares on the day I left.
I didn’t make anything.
The only good news was that the £1billion
owed to the bank stayed with the company rather
than me.“
He then managed to acquire a few million pounds
by mortgaging his house and investing the
money in various business ventures, such as
a health club business that he sold in 2001
for £3.9 million (adjusted for inflation
about £5.6 million today or about $9.4 million).
These days, he runs a jewellery business with
an estimated value of about £35 million or
$59 million.
When he’s not doing that, Ratner occasionally
earns extra money by giving speeches at business
conventions.
“I tell people that having a setback, whether
it’s going bankrupt, being divorced or ill,
doesn’t mean it is the end of you.
Getting my audience to laugh puts me on a
huge high and people now realise I am no longer
the arrogant snob they thought I was.”